ومن خانيونس ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
اسماعيل ابو عمر وكما قال الياس هناك
تقديرات بانه قد يسعى الجيش الاسرائيلي في
الايام المقبله لانهاء معاركه في خانيونس
ولكن حتى ذلك الحين المعارك قويه جدا ما
اخر المعلومات حول الاشتباكات
الجاريه نعم قبل الحديث عن الاشتباكات
الجاريه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال في مخيم خنوس تهين في حي الامل
قبل قليل قامت طائرات الاحتلال بقصف سياره
مدنيه في منطقه حي البراق وفي هذه اللحظات
نرى هذه السياره وتشتعل النيران في داخل
هذه السياره لا يستطيع حتى هذه اللحظه منذ
تقريبا ساعه والقصف طال هذه السياره لا
يستطيع احد الوصول الى هذه السياره وهناك
حسب شهود الاعيان بان هذه السياره بها عدد
من المواطنين وما زالت تحترق حتى هذه
اللحظه تحديدا في منطقه حي البراق الى
الغرب من محافظه خوس كانتت هذهه السياره
يعني يستقلها عدد من المواطنين يتوجهون
الى منطقه معسكر خانيونس تحديدا الى
مستشفى ناصر لكن قامت طائرات الاحتلال
بقصف هذه السياره وما زالت تشتعل وطواقم
الدفاع المدني وطواقم الاسعاف لا تستطيع
الوصول الى ذلك المكان وهي مناشده من قبل
المواطنين بضروره
ان يعني يتواصل او يصل تصل سيارات الاسعاف
والدفاع المدني الى هذه المنطقه من اجل
انتشال او انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من ركاب
هذه السياره التي تم استهدافها في منطقه
حي البراق